[Music]
coming up
celebs go all out for the 2021 grammy's
red carpet
dua doja we have some tape up here some
tape down here it's tape on my back
it's everywhere the baby may be a
pandemic but you were coming absolutely
they're gonna see this and so many more
i think it adds a couple pounds to me at
least
five to seven we're recapping the glam
that blew us away plus
the behind the scenes style secrets you
won't find anywhere else
just get ready our grammy's fashion
recap
starts now
hello everyone and welcome to et live's
the download i'm denny directo
the 2021 grammy awards gave us the
concert fix we've been craving this year
but also gave us some amazing fashion to
fawn over
to break down all of our favorite style
standouts i have an amazing panel of
guests including
celebrity stylist brett allen nelson who
styled
three people at the grammys last night
are you tired brett
i'm exhausted but i'm happy to be here
thank you for being here
also we have e.t styles senior producer
marisa runyan marissa we also had a late
night last night
we did but you know what it was worth it
because this was a real award show
i was so here for it i know let's get
right into it there's so much
there's so many looks to talk about
including dua lipa who's one of the
first looks i saw the night
you know with this fashion forward kind
of nod to share she
has become our future nostalgic fantasy
this red carpet look is
versace we saw it throughout the night
when she collected her grammy for best
pop vocal album and like i mentioned
there are a lot of comparisons
to share from the grammys back in 1974
and it's very young kevin fraser
actually got a chance to catch up with
dua
ahead of the grammy ceremony to talk
about the inspiration for her look
butterflies have had like a lot of
symbolism for me this year yeah and
it's actually got a lot of symbolism for
versace too so it's really cool to get
to
come together and make something cute
you know we love when fashion tells a
story right bruh uh what do you think
she was trying to say
with this look i mean she always sticks
with versace which i kind of love
it always like transcends with her and
every moment that she does
but it's beautiful versace always does
amazing things for her and
she looks like a legend and obviously
there's a lot of inspo from cher but
i love every piece of it she's so hot
she's so hot and the inches on that hair
chris
appleton snapped like it's so good um
did you catch that 1970s share vibe
i did i was here for it i
she was like enviable the whole night i
love
i'm just a sucker for a performance look
that starts fully clothed and ends
basically naked i love you so much
you have a reveal slugs were chef's kiss
i mean
the the big voluminous cape and just
whittling it down to just this like
little sparkly top and
and like panty was again like you said
so hot so sheer
so so modern at the same time i was
absolutely here for this she gave
us everything we wanted in a performance
look and it was just like she said she
talked so much about happiness and
happiness being a huge theme of her year
and a huge theme of her music
and you could see that in her
performance looks just bright pink
sparkly
shiny happiness we love a good costume
reveal but i also appreciated the nod to
her album future nostalgia it was a nice
way to kind of like
you know put a punctuation mark in that
explanation mark i should say
on this error for her but let's move on
to megan the stallion who also had a
huge night she won
three grammys last night her first time
ever but she gave us that classy
bougie bombshell moment on the red
carpet in this
dolce in gabbana i mean she
looks like a star i feel like there is a
lot of pressure
going into your very first grammys brett
how did you feel that she pulled this
off this red carpet look for her
grammy's debut
was was it unexpected for you i
didn't know what to expect from meg but
she looks super beautiful again she's
paying reference to a legend this is
very
marilyn monroe diamonds are a girl's
best friend but in orange which is such
a beautiful color on her i mean
she looks hot and her waist is cinched
eric archibald
killed it with her she looks beautiful
it's almost
unfair how effortless it looks to
hamarissa
it is and you know the thing that struck
me at first was the color
because the silhouette is so classic but
meg is so loud and bold and fun that i'm
so glad she wore a color
that matched that about herself even as
she's you know giving us the more
elegant you know lady side of her on the
red carpet i thought this was perfect
and i actually
didn't even i forgot it was her first
grammys because i feel like we've been
seeing her so much and we see her on
carpets
that you know it's amazing to me that
she has never been to the grammys before
like this
i know but she really showed out and
made a huge impression on us just with
that dress alone and it looked so good
when she was accepting that grammy's
standing next to beyonce
like somehow they didn't look like
halloween colors black and white it just
worked you know
uh but let's talk about her performance
looks too because this one struck me
i love a show girl moment and kind of
like with duolippa it started with like
a cape and like the headdress
and it came down to this brett what were
your thoughts on her performance
costumes
i mean i think it's great meg always
puts on a show
and she's got a lot of body yada yada so
she definitely showed it off and
i mean down to the tap dancers to the
guys in the nikes it was
it was a really cool moment and it was
as you guys said a huge night for her
and it was such a different look than
what we saw when she performed wap with
cardi b
i think she aligned with the theme of
cardi's futuristic
kind of like robot moment the metallics
i was living for this too i mean she did
not do any wrong here
right mercep i totally agree i was so
excited for this whole
moment with cardi between the giant
stripper shoe
and their metallic looks they're custom
by ray ortiz they were just
so cool so beautiful and like props to
them for managing to sing this
very x-rated song on national television
i was like how are they gonna pull this
off but they did and it was super sexy
and
they looked amazing doing it right
switching gears now to a look that i
felt was so emblematic of what you
should wear to the grammys because it
was fierce
and fearless and i'm talking about doja
cat who of course was styled
by brett ellen nelson uh brett you had
such a busy night like i said three
clients at the grammys
uh and there's two very different looks
that you styled
for joja last night she told us about
how fiercely creative you guys are
how did you guys come up with this
concept
i mean we're moving into a new album
cycle with dojo which is called planet
her
and so we definitely keep the idea of
futurism in
in our mind frame without looking like
the campy pinterest
future board um i knew when
we got the offers for grammys that i
wanted to go with my friend fausto
pagluci who just took over
uh cavalli and i gave him some keywords
and we talked about the idea of future
and color
and being tough and sexy and he brought
this motorcycle like
future queen to us and when doja saw it
she knew that was the look
i would love to know what your first
reaction was once she was
out of the makeup chair her hair was in
and like it just
came out the door what was your first
reaction i
i always feel like i have a huge smile
on my face with doja because she's like
my little sister at this point
so like when she comes in just like in
her
izzy miyaki pants and sweats like she
when she's all glammed up and done i
just have a huge smile to my face
because i'm so proud of her and she's
worked so hard
to be where she is now so you know i
just had a big ass smile on my face
sorry no please keep that smile going
because
she shared that same sentiment with et's
kelty night at rehearsals last week take
a look
working with brett is a blessing he's
incredible
like he he just he's like a genie like i
always say
he can like pull anything out of my
dreams and
nightmares and everything that i've ever
you know thought of so
um he nailed this one like he does with
with everything he put a lampshade on my
head one time i'll never forget
never come on
i'm such a sad like she makes me cry
because like she's such a
she's so sweet i've obviously seen this
interview and the first time i saw it i
had a tear in my because it's like
we've worked so hard and i'm so proud of
her
and especially because the grammys is
such a huge moment too so when you see
your friend really shine
and you helped her get there you know
like it's it's awesome to take it in
marissa what did you think of her tulips
last night i
loved her performance look and i
especially love when a performance look
is so different from what we see them in
on the carpet
she looked so fierce so cool in this
i i want to hear more about how you
created this look because this was a
custom john paul gautier
and it's like her face was just shining
through it's like you almost didn't see
anything else except her
her beautiful face it was just so so
cool
yeah that's what we really wanted i mean
again we're moving into this very future
world and gautier
i've been such a massive fan of since i
was so young and
we've been very lucky to
be using things for upcoming projects
and also
to have this amazing custom moment and i
told them i wanted it made in vinyl
which they kind of questioned at first
because they
it's not a very gautier fabric to use
but
the house is so happy and like i'm still
pinching myself there jean-paul gaultier
made us a custom look
oh it was so sick and i got i have to
ask for some t brett knowing what you
know about
future doja in this next album cycle
what can you tell us or how would you
describe it what
what can you tease i mean you guys
aren't ready we really want to send like
shuttle tickets to everyone to come to
planet earth
we're really creating futurism in a new
light
because i think as i mentioned before
like if you google
futuristic fashion it's always the same
thing we see silver chrome and metal
we're really trying to flip the switch
and
recreate the idea of what futurism is
and
everything i do with doja i try to stay
in our own lane
like we obviously pay homage to the
greats like she's a
massive nicki minaj stan and i love
nikki so
there's always a bit of inspiration from
those heavy rap girls but
we always try to be original and iconic
in our own way
consider our bags packed all right but
booking a one-way ticket to planet her
right after we wrap here tonight okay
all right moving on uh you know someone
who really showed up but also was a
thirst
trap harry styles a lot of people were
talking about harry and all of his looks
at the grammys including this
performance look this is gucci
uh he also rocked gucci for the red
carpet a big night for him as well he
won his first
grammy beating out his ex taylor swift
for best pop solo performance but she
definitely cheered him on
his friend lizzo backstage was hugging
him and loving up on him
everyone was having a harry styles
moment but i got to tell you i think
trevor noah
described the allure of harry styles
best last night take a look
ladies you better watch out because
he'll steal your heart and your dress
and he'll look damn good doing it give
it up for harry styles
i'm gonna start with you that was on
point but a lot has been said about uh
harry last night and his performance
looks
his whole looks all together uh you know
he sets the bar really high do you feel
like the moment lived up to your style
expectations of harry styles
yes 100 now i've been on the harry
styles train
like only for a couple years i wasn't on
it on the one direction years i've
jumped on recently so i am i'm loving
what he's doing through his personal
style and
a lot of the times in the past uh you
know recent appearances we've seen him
be really over the top and really taking
risks and trying more feminine pieces
and all sorts of things
but i really loved the paired back look
that he gave us last night i mean
the performance couldn't have been
hotter i'm sorry the amount
the amount of times i had to like stop
what i was doing and just
watch him it was it was so perfectly
paired
paired down i love that he had no shirt
on he looked so cool he had this like
old school like rockstar mick jagger
thing going on
just super hot and and really unexpected
i mean the feather boas i know they were
polarizing
they were i think they look like fur
actually not feathers but i was really
into it i thought it was very cool and
unexpected and
kind of irreverent and that's the fun
side of his uh style that i really love
and appreciate
i gotta be honest with you guys i am a
huge harry styles fan i love how much he
pushes boundaries especially in fashion
like that whole vogue spread i was
living for
but last night i could not deal with the
boa
i just couldn't i felt like it was out
of place i felt like he pulled out the
back of his closet
like that grinch fur did not do it for
me when he took it off and he's wearing
that shirtless leather gucci suit i go
i i was on a watermelon sugar high brett
what did you think of the boas
i honestly love that they changed every
time he was on camera
it was a different color boa every
single time and even
closer to the end of the show and maybe
i made this up in my mind but i swear
he was in the same suit but as boa
changed colors like three different
times
harry styles is so cool i want to be
harry styles
yeah i want to be with you why do i well
same i mean if that's an option maybe i
can convince them to
change out the feather boas i mean i
don't want to change him but
i just was on the fence about it i'm not
gonna lie y'all i'm not going i'll take
him with the boas so i get first option
it seems
i think you're gonna have to fight
olivia wilde for that one
i'll take you down olivia there you go
now we can't talk about fun
grammy's fashion without talking about
taylor swift who brought some
folklore florals oh i said it i got
through it
i did it at the grammys last night in
this custom oscar de la renta for her
red carpet
i mean brett florals for spring was it
groundbreaking for you
oh groundbreaking i honestly
listen this is a different look that we
haven't seen taylor in and it's sexy
fernando at oscar de la renta always
does something really special and
beautiful i love it i think she looks
beautiful
and she's not aged at all oh my gosh
it's
so true and i feel i love that it was so
symbolic also of this folklore era
you know but it was an elevated look
than what we've been used to during
quarantine
at the grammys uh we also got some
behind the scenes of the making of the
dress and obviously a lot of detail and
work
went into this garment marissa what were
your thoughts was
was it enough was it just enough or not
enough
i think it was just enough like you said
it goes perfectly
with the theme of her album and her
music right now
and i i love when artists take into
account where they're at
musically and where they are in their
creative head space
and translate that into what they wear
on the red carpet so i thought this was
delicate and pretty and
she looked like she was literally
plucked from a field of flowers and i'm
just a huge fan of oscar de la renta as
well i think the work that fernando and
kim do is so beautiful fernando and
laura
and this this dress actually today
it's now available online you can
actually buy this dress if you have a
cool
nine thousand dollars to spare um this
dress popped up today
so i i mean i've rarely or ever seen
that happen before where literally
someone wears something on the carpet
and then you can buy it but
this is the day and age we're in i can't
afford it so i'm just gonna watch from
afar i do appreciate that dress though
uh but moving on to perhaps the most
meme worthy look at the grammys
courtesy of noah cyrus brett let's talk
about this look that you styled uh she
was the first one to wear this couture
creation by scalparelli
and i know noah has spoken a lot
recently about setting herself apart
from her sister miley
was that all something you guys
considered when working on this look
with her
i you know the cyrus family is such an
iconic family and
miley has done some amazing looks
through her whole entire career but when
it came to noah and when she asked me to
do this
i really wanted to do something special
for her and
i immediately reached out to
schiaparelli and the moment that they
said yes i told noah it was our look
because nothing else we could have done
would have been
as big as a moment as as this look i
mean you could see it in the audience
when they were handing out the trophy
for best new artist i'm like
is she blocking any cameras you knew
noah cyrus was right there and i thought
that was such a moment
marissa what did you make of it i i'm
just a
sucker for a couture moment and i i love
seeing people take risks and
plucking something straight from the
runway and wearing it on the red carpet
i thought she looked like an
angel in a cloud and it was so beautiful
she looked so
fresh-faced she just looked like
literally an angel brett i i think this
was such a home run
yeah congratulations so much that was
like fashion
fashion fashion you know amazing amazing
speaking of fashion someone who i
thought was like a breakout fashion
star or in this case baby was the baby
last night i'm really excited to talk
about this he was wearing dolce
and gabbana on the red carpet as well as
for his performance
and i you know obviously at the grammys
you want to bring the fashion you want
to bring out some looks
this was so unexpected to me and because
it just felt so editorial and i'm like
is he the new face of dolce gabbana
because he should be like it was just
i was so impressed by it uh what did
what do you guys think this means for
his fashion moment moving forward
in the rest of his career i think it
would be a huge power move for dolce to
have him be the face of the company
i mean he's such a cool guy and it feels
sleek it feels different than
everybody else or every other male at
the awards show
i it's a really cool moment and
accessorized perfect
was this look unexpected to you marissa
yeah i didn't i didn't know what to
expect from the baby but i loved it
because of all these
same reasons it was rich it was
interesting the accessories were
beautiful i love that he went with a
full head to toe look
and i love that he coordinated with his
mom there was his mom with him on the
carpet
and he had such a beautiful family
moment and he also wanted to take
his daughter to the uh to the awards
last night but since uh due to covert
restrictions he couldn't
so he set up a red carpet at home and he
had a custom-made dress for her so she
could have her red carpet moment
i thought the whole thing i mean between
the look on him and his family
and this family moment it was
all perfectly perfectly coordinated and
in fact et's kevin
frazier talked to the baby ahead of the
grammys about those matching hats with
his mom
tell me about the hats real quick oh man
keith james you know shout out shout out
to my boy keith and james yes
my mom my mother has on the uh the
mustard yellow with the
with the red underlay you know
complimenting her dolce gabbana
custom handmade dress along with the
doshan gabana clutch bag and the dosha
and gabon shoes and you know mines it's
you know it's green with the red up
under there as you can see
i got it yeah it may be a pain but you
were coming oh absolutely
i'm telling you my new favorite fashion
star i stan
yeah he's so sleepy even i wouldn't even
get into his performance look which was
also so
amazing and completely different right
the whole
accessories and the accessories he
turned it out look at him right there
such a handsome film i can't wait to see
what he a-plus
uh let's now go to brett's third client
at the grammy's lizzo
i feel like if i was a celebrity stylist
i would want to style someone like lizzo
her personality and also just her style
like she is so fun
uh brett you know you've worked with
lizzo for several awards show now what's
your process like working with her to
create
a custom look and also a moment like
this one last night
as you said lizzo is so fun i mean she
exudes happiness and so every time i
enter a new project with her
i still want that to show and she told
me when we were
when we were coming up with the idea for
these looks that she wanted to feel like
an icon
she wanted it to be sexy and i knew in
that moment
i wanted to reach out to olivier uh at
balman
and i i love these looks the colors of
them are bright they're happy
it's not too much because you know she's
a presenter we didn't want to go
super crazy she just wanted to look sexy
and i think
that is that she i mean she looks so
sexy but i do have a question because
she was presenting she wasn't performing
and you know you typically see
presenters in just one look she rocked
two
so was i mean did she want to was that
always the plan
or were there two dresses you guys just
couldn't choose from
well we i had them do two dresses for us
because i always
want an option i don't want to just be
stuck with one thing and she was
obsessed with both of them
and she wanted to do a switch over to
this pink dress for the presenting
yeah and then her little marilyn moment
there oh she rocked that lip sync on
that reel i saw that
i also love the accessories uh how fun
was it to see lizzo especially because
she uh also presented the first award of
the night
uh i'm sorry i missed your question no i
was asking marissa what did you
how fun was it to see lizzo at the
grammys in two looks uh
because of course she also presented
that first award of the night i i live
for somebody who wants to do a change up
because i think it's so much fun like
you're gonna you're going to the grammys
if you have two dresses wear them i love
that she did that um i thought she
looked like a like a prom queen
i thought she just looked exactly like
you'd want her to
fun happy light bright i i
i'm just such a huge fan and i love
every time you see her you
you feel as you feel the happiness come
off of her you really do
and it's so amazing to hear brett that
she's just like that in real life
i believe that she's the best and
finally let's talk about some
a plus accessories last night billy
eilish uh her performance look
was this headpiece and then also the red
carpet look had like the
the bucket hat um brett what did you
think do you feel like she's finally
starting to break out a little bit from
what we're used to seeing from her
at these events i don't know i i think
this feels like classic billy to me like
it still
fits into the world of things that we've
seen her do
billy's so cool i mean i want all her
wardrobe
minus the big nails i want all that
wardrobe i know she really rocks the
nails
uh what did you think of her accessories
last night marissa
okay i loved what she had on again i'm
such a billy fan
i loved her performance look i thought
that was kind of fun and different i
loved her headpiece there
i would love to see her ditch the green
i i loved how in the beginning of her
career she was kind of changing her hair
a lot she was blue and then she got
darker and then she
kind of changed it she's she's really
committed to the green roots we've seen
it for a long time on her i would love
to see her change it up
uh but you know what i don't want to
tell her not to do her not to be her
because i love her for who she is but
you know i also love to see people take
risks and change things so
i'm here for a hair change billy i feel
like i'm seeing baby steps with her
evolution when it comes to style
but also she's just someone who stays so
true to us herself like you said
but the thing that we also need to
recognize is how much she coordinated
with her
brother phineas for both looks for the
performance also when they were
accepting that grammy for record of the
year
i love a quart moment especially between
siblings it just worked
you know yeah they have such a special
relationships
too so it doesn't if they weren't
coordinating i feel like that would be
weird
so they really make that happen
perfectly i feel like i could be part of
the the family now that i'm wearing this
today but i'm gonna say you could jump
right in there
right well we can't talk accessories
without talking about the one we saw
consist
consistently throughout the night which
were masks there were so many
celebrities wearing masks last night
and a lot of them coordinated with their
outfits who did it the best for you
marissa let's start with you
do you have a favorite mask oh you know
what i've got to go with taylor swift
because that was a beautifully
embroidered perfectly coordinated mask
that literally took the fabric from her
dress i mean a lot of people did that
the same fabric but for some reason that
one for me
just was so beautiful i loved it
brentwood
right with dojo do you guys coordinate
that were you thinking about the mask
when you were styling the whole look
we for sure did i wanted her to look
like a mortal kombat character yeah
she does yeah it looks she's like final
fight
that's exactly right uh for me you know
beyonce we haven't talked about beyonce
yet but
i was like is she wearing an n95 mask
with this look only she could make this
look so good you know she had this mask
and with the
sunglasses and the long leather gloves
with the nails and the earrings
it all just worked together um so i have
to give my girl queen bee who made
history last night at the grammys
a shout out for looking so effortless
and yet so chic
she was trying to be incognito right
exactly she was trying to be a little
incognito but we saw her we're glad
she's there
brett we're so glad you joined us today
marissa as always thank you guys so much
for talking fashion
there's so much more to talk over at et
online.com forward slash style
but we'll see you guys tomorrow with a
new episode of the download bye everyone
[Music]